good evening today marked one year since
Russia's invasion of Ukraine thanks for
joining us at 11 I'm Denise Valdez and
I'm Brian Loftus during the last 12
months many here in Las Vegas have
jumped into help in any way they could
including one woman who flew to the
Ukrainian border to help refugees Sasha
Loftus spoke with her tonight and she
joins us right now with more Sasha
Denise and Brian the woman I spoke with
dropped everything last year to fly to
Poland and help millions of Ukrainian
refugees entering that country she sat
down with me tonight to share more on
their resilience and how many have been
through this past year
it's been one year since life in Ukraine
came to a startling halt
since Russia's Invasion cities have
crumbled thousands have been killed and
millions forced to escape I wanted to go
because I knew I could do something many
fleeing into Poland which prompted Kathy
Healy to travel there all the way from
Las Vegas to help Healy spent more than
a month camping at the border as a Red
Cross volunteer feeding and clothing
those who got out people were so
desperate for just
A simple piece of bread
they were desperate just to have their
child stop crying she says at the time
no one had any idea the war would last
this long but she believes her work
truly made a difference the goal of a
volunteer was just to give them a smile
many of those she still keeps in touch
with still haven't been able to go back
to their home country and though it's
still hard to watch such sadness and
pain Healey says the people she knows
will always rely on their ultimate
strength survival
makes you tough and these people are
tough
Kathy says she still keeps in touch with
two women she met in Poland last year
who had just escaped Ukraine she says
while they're safely in other countries
they tell her their husbands are still
in the country fighting